ce qui fait de plus de tacles dans les
messieurs pour le trophée du meilleur
table
[Musique]
camille combal
auger mateusz sur nrj 12 et comme j'ai
passé un week-end de merde mais pas à ce
point là
matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
la peine parce que tu as un jean guénard
parce que j'ai un scoop tu verras ça
arriverait un jour mon fils mj a pas il
ya eu ce 7,7 cette affaire malheureuse
l'an dernier j'étais venu vous voir
j'étais venu en vélo parce que là ce
qu'on peut expliquer pourquoi vous étiez
venu en vélo c'est pas du tout parce que
vous êtes écolo c'est parce que vous
vouliez que les caméras vous mais non
pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
cyril hanouna et à bernard montiel qui
me dit long non l'an dernier c'est alma
et non pas à venir merci bernard montiel
breuilly il est beaucoup plus efficace
par sms bravo bernard au thème
ludivine lovet torride
les vélos j'adore j'adore et qui chante
bien aussi je les ai vus sur les
empharés je suis très fan j'ai enfin ce
match c'est surtout pour une fois ça
nous change de ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du beau monde
tu as fait le meilleur tacle de l'année
pour vous
bah je vous le dire oui jean luc non
parce que ce qui était bizarre vous vous
apercevez quand même le defensive back
asap chatel animation en photo c'est
brest et nantes deux connus de leurs
mots et anna corbella est le gagnant
matthieu delormeau
mathieu le labo le meilleur 4 de l'année